hi everyone so my name is Gabriel I'm a
computational scientist based in San
Francisco California
um I'm the author of plasma physics
package plasma JL making tributor to a
physics informed neural network package
neuropde.jl and I'm a product designer
at subtech Inc here in San Francisco
um today I want to talk to you about
developing battery materials of python
and in particular I want to talk about
an interesting field of computational
physics that have gotten to know this
year and this is a field of density
functional Theory or DFT DFT tries to
solve the problem of determining the
properties of matter theoretically
that is it tries to know what a material
that is basically a periodic collection
of atoms will do without performing an
experiment going to a lab or touching
matter at all
um so purely theoretically and Beyond
understanding how how it works today I
want to talk to you
um and look at how DFT can be used to
evaluate the performance of materials
used in battery electrodes so how we can
do that how so how we can get DFT
applied to batteries and do all that in
Python
um so why is this interesting
um and particularly for computer science
data science audience why is this
interesting I think this is an
interesting problem because one it is a
tool for understanding matter which is
all around us and it's um very
fundamental
two is that I it is a term machinist
dream is what I like to call this which
is it is a part of physics where you can
use computers to simulate how actual
physical systems behave with high
accuracy which was one of the original
goals of computer Pioneers so you can
think about the eniac computer helping
with the Manhattan Project as an example
um another thing is that simply it's
useful
um it's many fields within physics and
engineering and chemistry require
understanding and controlling of the
properties of matter at the level of
individual atoms
um and molecules for Progress so you can
think of batteries which is the
electrochemical cell case you can think
of catalysts which are on these chemical
compounds that speed up can speed up
chemical processes
and you can make your superconductors
which are these very interesting
materials that um that lose their
resistance and when their temperature is
lowered after two very cold and
temperatures
um and this field is generally useful
enough to have been awarded the Nobel
Prize in 1998 so on DFT and its
development
um were awarded the Nobel pricing
chemistry in 1998
um and I think most importantly
um more knowledge of computer science
software engineering and data science
can help Advance the field of density
functional Theory now more than ever and
we'll talk about that we'll talk about
how machine learning has changed in the
field we'll talk about high throughput
density functional Theory and the
software engineering challenges that it
faces so you know maybe I can get one of
you one or two of you at least a bit a
little bit interested in the field to
look further and so at
um this this talk is is for beginners
but it might feel a little daunting or
physics e at points but I hope it all
makes sense at the end
um so I'll follow um the David Shaw's
approach to introducing the subject
which I think is pretty clear
um and we can sort of like take it from
there and I'll be here for questions
foreign
hopefully you're at least somewhat
interested in what DFT is and as a way
of understanding matter
um but how does do we understand matter
um how can one know how matter behaves
and how can DFT help
well in short we generally understand
matter by using quantum mechanics to get
to the electronic structure of a
material and quantum mechanics is in
advance of physical theory of developed
in the 20th century by neospora Max
Planck's countless others
um and it's quite useful but technically
to determine the behavior of matter we
like the technical description which
we'll start with and I know it's
unintelligible and we'll slowly chip
away at it and and make sense of it is
that we're trying to find the ground
state or the lowest energy of
non-relactivistic electrons basically of
electrons for arbitrary positions of
nuclei within the born Oppenheimer
approximation
it's okay if none of this makes sense
yet I promise you in the next five
minutes
um it probably will
um so
um yeah
so let's talk about the problem
statement so what are we trying to solve
here if you want to understand matter
what is the problem I'm trying to solve
so let's imagine a situation where we
like to describe the properties of some
wall defined collection of atoms you can
think of it as a like an isolated
molecule for Catalyst or the atoms
defining the crystal of an interesting
mineral like lithium in our example
right
um The Funnel fundamental thing we want
to know about these atoms is what is
their energy and how does their energy
change if we move the atoms around
so all we're doing here is accounting
for energies at different states and
using that to determine properties of
something we're interested in
so how do we do that first of all we
need to find the atom where's the atom
um so we want to know how the energy of
atoms change when we move the atoms
around
but to do that we need to know where the
atom is
um simplistically speaking all we need
to know to Define where the atom is is
to Define where the nucleus is and where
the electrons are in the atom
um so what we do is an approximation so
and we we can do that it's worth
pointing out that each Proton or Neutron
and nucleus has more than 1800 times the
mass of an electron which means that the
nucleus moves much lower than the
electrons which lets us break the
problem of
um defining where the atom is into two
parts the first part is we solve for
fixed positions of the atom nuclei the
equations that describe the electron
motion
and then we account for the nuclei in
motion so the separation of nuclei and
electrons into separate mathematical
problems is what we call the born
Oppenheimer approximation
um which is exactly what we talked about
here so within the born Oppenheimer
approximation we're going to know the
energy of these electrons while keeping
the nuclei constant and then adding the
nuclei motion afterwards so we want to
find the the lowest energy of the
um
system in that approximation so that's
the first thing first part of this it
starts to make a little bit more sense
um and once we have the position of the
atom we can start to answer how the
energy of the material change as we move
the atoms around
so how do we find the energy
um well in quantum mechanics we do that
by solving the schrodiger equation which
is here's a coffee mug version of it
which is basically the hamiltonian the
weight function is equal to the energy
eigenvalue
the wave function
um
but you know this is like just the
simple version
um when we have multiple electrons
interacting multiple nuclei the equation
looks a little bit uglier which is that
which is what you see a little bit below
um and not that it matters but in case
you're curious the terms
um there are mean the kinetic energy the
interaction and energy between the
electrons and the nuclei and then the
interaction energy between the different
electrons
um so that that's basically the way
generally it is done in quantum
mechanics but this approach has several
problems so here's PSI which cannot be
found without simultaneously considering
the individual electron wave functions
associated with all the other electrons
so in other words
um Schrodinger's equation is what is
called the many body problem which is
computationally trouble it's just an
extremely difficult
um computational problem so for example
if we are interested in a single
molecule of
um yeah the interest in single molecule
of CO2
um
we have a problem that is 66 dimensional
um so 66 dimensional function that you
need to solve computationally so if any
of you have done scientific Computing
you know that this is like a very high
dimensional problem
um very yeah basically
incredibly impractical and if we were
interested in a nano cluster of a
hundred uh Platinum atoms
um the full wave function requires more
than 23 000 Dimensions which is not
solvable at all with our current
computational structures
it's just not manageable due to this
thing called the cursive dimensionality
so if you're trying to compute a a
scientific Computing problem
um with high Dimensions each Dimension
makes the problem exponentially marked
costly so at the moment that you're at
yeah more than 10 Dimensions is already
hard 23 000 is an understanding it's not
not feasible at all
um and by the way this is why quantum
computers are important because it would
allow us to solve those problems without
the approximations we use to solve them
right now but until we have them what do
we do how is this done scientists do
know the structure of atoms and no no
the energy of compounds all the time so
how do we do that
and this is where density functional
Theory comes in so the DFT is basically
a very smart reformulation of the
problem of finding the ground state or
low estate energy
um
based on the Schrodinger equation
um and it basically manages to make the
previously Impossible Project a problem
manageable
um
and basically the reformulation
is based on the following theorem which
is the ground state energy from
Fairgrounds equation as a unique
functional of the electron density what
do I mean by that this means exactly
that there is there exists a one-to-one
mapping between the ground state wave
function
underground state electron density
um or basically the electron density
um of the ground state determines all
the properties of
um
of the system that you're interested in
um which is
which is really good so why is this
important is it means that we can think
about solving the schroederer equation
by finding a function of three spatial
variables which is the electron density
what is the density of the the electron
the XYZ that's all we need rather than
just trying to solve a function that um
grows exponentially which is the
schroederer equation so
um
for it's very a good example is that for
the Nano cluster of 100 atoms
um that we talked about that would need
23 000 Dimensions
um
the DFT would would allow for that to be
solved with only three dimensions which
is a much more solvable situation
and if the law this loss of Dimension
confuses you just um for those who know
physics remember that the wave function
is not observable so only the
probability density of the wave function
is and that is captured through the DFT
approach which is finding the electron
density
but what is this functional look like
um we talked about this functional and
the the F and DFT the density functional
Theory but well what does it look like
there's another problem right the
theorem that we looked at that said that
it existed did not saying anything about
what
um the functional actually is what it
looks like uh it only says it exists
um and it has a general form
um which you can see on the screen
basically we we split the functional
into the known and the unknown parts of
um
of it and basically
um we account for kinetic energies and
interactions between electrons and and
nuclei
um but we don't actually know what this
exactly looks like so
um there's but there's a second theorem
that helps us which is which says that
the elect the second theorem says that
the electron density that minimizes the
energy of the overall functional is a
true electron denser density
corresponding to the full solution of
the schroederer equation
um what do I mean by that generally it
means that we find a functional by
um what we call in quantum mechanics
variational principle which is you pick
a trial functional
and then we minimize it which is a
computational problem it's like make an
educated guess
pick it you know minimize it
um until it gets until it converges and
that is the the electron density and
that will give you the energy that
you're looking for
which is exactly what the theorem is
sort of like
um hinting at which is quite useful
okay so that was a lot of physics
um but I it boils down for a quick recap
um this is very esoteric at some point
um and thank you for sticking around if
you did
um
it's basically the recap is we we figure
out how matter behaves through quantum
mechanics
um by finding the minimal energy of the
atoms and how that energy changes we
um we we know how matter behaves
um so what we want to do is find a
minimal energy of the atoms we do so by
solving Sugar's equation for a group of
atoms
but solving schroederer's equation is
hard
um it doesn't scale well it grows
exponentially as you have more and more
atoms so it becomes very complicated and
not feasible so we come up with an
equivalent formulation of Sugar's
equation called density functional
Theory
and the this Theory says that a 3D
functional so the the electron density
three-dimensional will give us all the
information we need to retrieve the
ground state energy
um of a system
and we find that functional by making an
initial educated guess
of what what it is and then minimizing
that function until it converges and
then we can use that to find the energy
of the system which is what we want to
be able to determine how matter behaves
but what about batteries right I just
looked at a bunch of physics a bunch of
chemistry
how how does it say anything about a
macro system how do Adam say anything
about the macro system
of batteries that we are interested in
well
electrochemical batteries are basically
two electrodes
um a cathode and a nano separated by an
electrolyte
and the electrodes are basically
um
compounds and they're they can be
described very accurately by their
crystal structure or atomic structure
um and these electrons they play a huge
role in the performance of a battery
they determine how stable the battery is
a determine is power density it's energy
density sector liberal voltage it's
cycling stability and more
and it turns out that to some
approximation all those properties can
be determined from the electronic
structure of the molecules that form the
electrons and thus they can be
determined through DFT
which is amazing so you start with atoms
and you know the atom structure is
something you use DFT to to get their
energies and that that itself can help
you determine the macro properties of uh
a material that you can use for
Batteries which we find fascinating
a simple example of how this can be done
is to get the equilibrium voltage of a
standard lithium-ion battery there is a
simple approximation that you can see on
the screen which says that the
equilibrium voltage is basically equal
to
um
the post yeah the electron voltage is
basically equal to the energy post
interpolation minus the energy
pre-intercalation minus the energy of
lithium divided by a constant and how
many electrons changed in this reaction
so basically you have three energies
that you're looking for so those are
three DFT calculations that you you can
make on your in your computer at home so
really cheap calculations
that can tell you the equilibrium
voltage of of a battery you're
interested in before you have to go to a
lab to build it so you prefer you need
to touch anything without any any
experimental
um involvement can give you a good
approximation of what it is which I find
um
pretty impressive truly
and how do we do that in Python so in
Python we there are several packages for
DFT uh a lot of them and languages that
are older than me
um
but in Python we can do that with ASC
and gpot which are very interesting and
good packages and I'll just walk you
through a a bit of a code of what that
would look like and we can just do line
by line so we import
um
from from me I see the atom structures
from gpot will import the calculators we
give it a name and in line five we
determine a parameter none of this is
like very interesting but around line a
it gets quite interesting which is we we
make a lithium structure so what we we
set an atom
um a lithium atom we Define its cell so
it's crystal structure to
um look like so so you basically Define
a matrix to say where the lithium atoms
are and then you say that this is a
periodic boundary condition so this will
repeat itself
around line 15 we set up a DFT
calculator so it's like we have the
structure now I want to calculate the
energy of the structure so I set up a
calculator in line 17 18 19. you don't
need to worry about what the cutoffs and
so on mean yet and then I attach this
calculator to the bulk in line 20.
and then basically what I do is I get
the potential energy
um
which is the energy we're looking for in
line 23 and then I print it and that
said with with those 25 lines of code I
can determine the energy of lithium that
you see here on the right which is quite
um fascinating I find
um
we can do a bit of a live demo
um let's see here so this is my
workstation of uh let me zoom in for you
um so this is my workstation of um a
battery system I was working on in the
summer which is the lithium oxide
battery system and in this world you can
see that I set uh I set a few compounds
here so I Define them I have some
corrections this is a bit more advanced
this is like production code
um but I get there are potential
Energies
very simply here and then I use the that
potential energy to get different values
or different things I'm interested in
and then get aspects of the battery
system so it's energy density is
volumetric energy density it's specific
capacity
um and then it can also get the
electronic structure of the compounds
I'm interested in and generate those
graphs that you see here
um on the right which
um are quite cool
um
yeah so
let me go back to presenting
thank you
um you can email me at
um this address if you want to talk if
you can follow me on Twitter if you want
to stay in touch
um but beyond that I really appreciate
your time and I'll take questions now
oh thank you very much for your talk
today
oh okay I give everyone a couple of
seconds to put in their questions
because we've got plenty of time
and I've got us
a little question so what what
originally got you into data science and
programming
um I've been doing this since I was 17
or 16.
um what got me into
um
data science for scientific Computing it
was a a new numerical analysis class I
took in college so I thought it was just
fascinating that we could use computers
to solve really hard
um mathematical problems
um and not just toy problems that you
can do it with um pencil and paper so
sort of seeing the capability of
computers and
understanding reality around us God
means data science
oh
excellent and here's our first question
from uh Mila what is the system size
you're working with how does the
calculation speed scale the system size
um the system size wall that we work on
with batteries is like
at the
at the worst case scenario there at the
nanoscale so it's it's uh
um a few hundred atoms at the worst case
scenario and um the calculation speed
um at the worst case scenario is already
pretty
hi so most of what super computers do
actually is DFT calculations it's a big
chunk a big percentage of their workload
so it's a lot of cameras running these
calculations but for small systems of
like 10 atoms or so you can run them in
like 20 minutes in your computer at home
so you you have the ranges of like I can
do some simple stuff and approximations
with
um at home just in my computer and then
if I wanted understand nanoclusters then
I probably need a supercomputer